all right tonight the vindication
continues we have a lot of brand-new
information to share with you the truth
about the Russia investigation is being
exposed as a sham a democratic political
operation and it has now turned into a
witch-hunt the entire basis of Robert
Muller's so-called investigation is
based and predicated on a lie and a
conspiracy theory that was cooked up by
the Obama administration by Democrats
and by your liberal news media as an
excuse for why Hillary Clinton lost the
election that was never supposed to
happen and for over a year what does it
Bend Trump Russia Trump Russia collusion
collusion collusion we have no evidence
to date the only evidence that we do
have tonight is that Hillary Clinton
bought and paid for a salacious phony
document filled with Russian lies to try
and influence all of you during that
election
that's what Muller should really be
looking into but instead his
investigation is now morphed into a
democratic political hit job to remove a
duly elected president from office and
used the powerful tools of intelligence
and the FISA courts to do it now with
more damaging information coming out
every day
it looks like Special Counsel Robert
Muller and his partisan hacks they are
trying now to change the narrative with
their lamestream media friends with
selective leaking today every one of
them is a non-story not worthy of your
attention unless you work for the fake
news media now before we get to
tonight's new information remember this
Comey is corrupt as they come he gave
those memos to the Columbia professor
for the very purpose of leaking to the
press so a special counsel would be
appointed hoping that this would all
come to pass and Comey also reportedly
coordinated his congressional testimony
with Robert Muller that sounds like
collusion and in spite of these facts
the delusional Comey he's actually
trying to fashion himself as a martyr as
he recently tweeted good to read reports
of people standing up for what they
believe in then he quotes dr. Martin
Luther King jr. the ultimate measure of
a man is not where he stands in moments
of comfort and convenience but where he
stands at times the challenge in
controversy wait a minute he put the fix
in so Hillary wouldn't be charged in
spite of the evidence he knew existed
this is an embarrassment a national
disgrace and beyond laughable he
deserved to be fired we'll explain why
in a minute and also tonight we have
more evidence of just how fraudulent
unethical and nefarious Muller's
investigation really is now here are the
new texts just released today between
anti Trump FBI officials which confirms
everything we have been telling you on
May 19th
two days after Robert Muller appointed
the special counsel struck rights to
page you and I both know the odds are
nothing if I thought it was likely I'd
be there no question I hesitate in part
because of my gut sense and concern
there's no big there their meaning Trump
Russia collusion so you have struck he
was a high-ranking intelligence official
at the FBI that specialized in Russia
signed the paperwork to start the entire
Russian investigation knowing there's no
there there in other words it's always
been a hoax and this proves it it was
part of an attempt to stop Trump a from
winning and then to remove him from
office and if it means breaking the law
using the intelligence community so be
it we never should have gone down this
road and the mainstream media and their
hacks in the media CNN and MSNBC every
broadcast channel New York Times
Washington Post they have been giving
you nothing but lies and propaganda now
for a year and now those involve those
responsible for crimes that were
committed they are now trying to cover
it up they're not going to get away with
it when all is said and done this is
going to make Watergate look like a kid
stealing candy from a store and as we
were reported yesterday five months of
key text messages are missing between
struck and page here's what happened
during this critical time frame this is
from December 14 2016
- May 17 2017 now a March President
Trump member he claimed yeah they were
wiretapping a trump towel we broke that
nearly a year ago right here on this
program then BuzzFeed published their
story in the five missing months the
Clinton bought and paid for phony
lying dossier that was in January all of
a sudden the text stopped and that was
used in part later on to get the FISA
warrant to spy on the Trump campaign
remember that it was before that and
later that month former national
security adviser Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn he's interviewed by the
FBI and wouldn't look habbit it was
Peter struck who actually was the
official that oversaw that interview and
on May 9th the FBI director James Comey
was fired and then on May 17th Robert
Muller was named a special counsel now
those are the major events and how
conveniently it happens that the
messages some 50,000 of them this is the
time period where struck in pages
messages are missing and the FBI is
trying to blame it on Samsung who
supplied the phones you've got to be
kidding me
it's the FBI that specializes in
intelligence and evidence gathering they
can't find the messages I don't believe
that's possible and given the inherent
anti-trump bias that we have seen from
Strunk and Paige they hated Trump and
their involvement in almost everything
involving the Russia investigation well
we must now know what they were talking
about during these five critical months
the FBI should find those messages maybe
make a call to Samsung because if you
can't get it I bet they can now there's
also a stunning new revelation tonight
about these missing text messages
congressman trey Gowdy is saying that
there is a message between struck and
page about the leading these text
conversations you can't make this up for
a novel look at this new information lay
aside this glaring five-month gap in
text that the world's premier law
enforcement agency somehow this lay that
aside what we have seen what Johnny and
I saw today was a text about not keeping
text we saw more manifest bias against
President Trump all the way through the
election into the transition hatred of
Trump bias against Trump and not keeping
the text messages well that sounds like
obstruction of justice and by the way
it's not the first time is it that we've
all seen this happen every single
solitary time the
Obama administration and their officials
are backed into a corner and in serious
legal trouble all of a sudden all the
evidence just magically disappears for
example this is their modus operandi
Hillary Clinton
33000 subpoenaed emails deleted and just
to make extra extra shor acid-washed
bleach bit the whole entire hard drive
to make sure the evidence is completely
destroyed and just in case it made it to
one of our blackberries or mobile
devices most he sends an 8 out with a
hammer boom let's smash that sucker and
the only phones they gave the FBI they
have no SIM cards I'm sure just an
accident right you believe that I'll
show you a bridge to nowhere then
there's also the IRS targeting
conservatives remember that scandal the
emails from corrupt official Lois Lerner
they disappeared for two years and the
IRS claimed at the time they were lost
because of a system crash and we can't
forget about debbie Wasserman Schultz or
IT aid and the reports of smashed hard
drives in his garage
now predictably the aides lawyer denied
it happened now I know this is a lot to
take in
let me slow down here but there's even
more new information tonight we'll be
giving you to you throughout the hour
according to congressman John Ratcliffe
struck and Paige were also talking about
imagine this a secret society meeting
the day after President Trump won the
election who's in the secret society
let's see it could it be page and struck
and mccabe and call me and let's see
Bruce or could it be rod Rosenstein who
else is in the special secret society is
it aren't they supposed to be
transparent what's this we learned today
about information that after in the
immediate aftermath of his election that
there may have been a secret society of
folks within the Department of Justice
and the FBI to include page instruct
that would be working against them I'm
not saying that actually happened but
when folks speak in those terms they
need to come forward to it explain the
context with which they use those terms
as you just heard congressman Ratcliffe
say there's no concrete evidence yet
that the secret society ever met but
here's what we do know
struck and page and who we think is the
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe we're
meeting about remember the insurance
policy just in case Hillary lost the
election it's like dying if you're forty
and all of the other evidence in the
scandal points to one simple fundamental
basic fact top-ranking Obama
administration officials in the
Department of Justice in the FBI not
rank-and-file the top people protected
Hillary Clinton from prosecution
we know that happen and then they use
that pony Russian dossier that Hillary
bought and paid for full of Russian
salacious lives to go after the Trump
campaign to try and influence the
election after all it worked in stealing
the primary from poor Bernie Sanders and
as we have now been saying for months
the fix was in in the Clinton email
investigation why because they wanted
Hillary to run they didn't want Trump to
win now here's why another text message
from Peter struck and Lisa page appears
to show that they and Obama's Attorney
General Loretta Lynch they all knew that
Clinton wouldn't be prosecuted by the
way before they ever interviewed Clinton
or the other main participants in all of
this they didn't do the investigation
remember in May James Comey and Peter
struck and other top FBI officials they
were drafting the exoneration of Hillary
months before they ever interviewed her
and seventeen other key witnesses how
can you actually exonerate somebody
before ever talking to them that's
called the fix being in that's being
rigged that is corruption 101 let's take
a look at James Comey denying under oath
that he reached his legal conclusion
before interviewing Hillary Clinton now
remember we have all the different
drafts and his original drafts all
pointed to a case of Hillary being
guilty as hell what's this director did
you make the decision not to recommend
criminal charges relating to classified
information before or after Hillary
Clinton was interviewed by the FBI on
July the second after but if if
colleagues of ours believe I am lying
about when I made this decision please
urge them to contact me private
so we can have a conversation about this
all I can do is tell you again the
decision was made after that because I
didn't know what was gonna happen in
that interview she maybe lied during the
interview and away we could prove I'll
call you can I have your number I have a
lot of questions for you sounds to me
like Comey lied in that case under oath
because we know we have the drafts how
he was exonerating clinton months before
her FBI interview and tonight just
breaking Politico is now reporting this
hour that congressman Ratcliffe is
saying he wants to interview Comey again
under oath about all these
inconsistencies in his previous
testimony let's go back to the timeline
at the end of June of 2016
Bill Clinton decides to meet Loretta
Lynch remember that on the tarmac for 40
minutes they're talking about their
grandkids and then on July 1st Lynch
says she's going to step away from the
investigation she will accept whatever
the FBI concludes remember she
encouraged Comey it's a matter it's not
an investigation this is all before
Hillary Clinton three days before she
was ever even interviewed that happened
on the 4th of July weekend so after
Lynch's statement that she was taking a
backseat backseat
struck writes his mistress girlfriend
page timing looks like hell page replies
yeah that's all full timing and then
later adds it's a real Profile in
Courage since she knows no charges will
be brought they had an interviewed
Killary Clinton yet four days later they
finally interviewed Hillary Clinton on
the third day then Comey comes out with
what he was already writing in early May
in his press conference giving Hillary
Clinton a pass on everything so struck
new page new Comey new Lynch knew and I
assume Andrew McCabe knew as well
nothing was going to happen to Hillary
because the fix was in and up Lisa page
knew and that probably means she was
advising deputy FBI director Andrew
McCabe so what else are they lying about
will they aware the FBI was giving
Clinton cover and if Comey Lynch and all
these top law enforcement officials knew
that this was their agreement not to go
after Clinton because they wanted her in
the race to defeat Donald Trump because
they know better than you who should be
president then there's a pretty darn
good chance that someone in the Obama
White House also was doing the wink and
nod thing and they knew the fix was in
in other words the fix was it it was
rigged
now there's another component of the
story we have even more breaking news
tonight about the effort by
congressional Republicans to release the
four-page classified memo that exposes
the FISA abuses against the Trump
campaign Byron York reporting nearly 200
members of Congress have now seen this
and Fox News is reporting tonight that
the memo could be released any day now
but we're still calling on you the
American people once again call up your
members of Congress to man that the memo
be released release the memo call the
number at the bottom of your screen
two oh two two to four thirty one twenty
one tell your members of Congress we
deserve to know the truth about what is
likely the biggest scandal in American
history there's so much information
there's so many players involved in all
of this let me tie it together Hillary
Clinton rigged the primary if you're a
Bernie Sanders supporter you should be
pissed why you're not I don't know even
though there is incontrovertible
evidence she broke the law James Comey
Andrew McCabe Peter struck Lisa Paige
Loretta Lynch all put the fix it and
allowed her to stay in this presidential
race they ignored the rule of law the
Constitution and Clinton and the DNC
that she controlled then spent over 12
million dollars to influence the
election with a bought and paid for
dossier full of Russian lies and
propaganda that was shipped off to the
compliant media the Obama administration
weaponized the powerful tools of
intelligence that we need to keep our
country safe but in this case they used
it to target members of the Trump
campaign this so you understand is so
much bigger than Watergate
it's about our Constitution about the
rule of law it has been shredded all
because powerful people at the highest
level in the DOJ and the FBI thought
they knew better than you
to who should be President there needs
to be serious ramifications if we're
going to save our country and all of
this people must be held accountable
they must be investigated they must be
indicted and probably many of them
thrown in jail